les joues à mes rêves sont pour toi que
si vous le laissez mes parents
mais notre amour nous appartient
on va
l'éloignement aide parfois
comme le soleil qui disparaît comme un
été comme un dimanche
j'ai peur du vide de l'absence
du temps
et les oiseaux
le monde de neige
j'ai peur de toi je marquerai
bien merci de mettre jamais
on se quitte plus depuis longtemps
depuis nos premiers rubans des Collières
j'imagine moi la vie sans toi que le
ciel de Yasmina sans lumière
et moi je t'aime petite sœur j'étais ma
avec tout mon coeur et sans mon corps et
moi je t'aime
petite sœur
aimerais-je un homme aussi fort notre
état civil est différent on n'a pas le
même sang dans les verres
celle de l'âme pas celle qui verse des
larmes au baptême
et moi je t'aime
petite sœur je fais ma vague tout mon
cœur et sans mon corps et moi je sais
même petite sœur
aimerait jeune homme aussi fort tu me
dis ton mari tes amours ton ennuis ce
monument si solide
mais tu m'entends mieux quand je me tais
tu sais le moindre secret de mairie de
t'en as pas beaucoup et moi je t'aime
moi je t'aime petite sœur
et l'amitié c'est l'amour du cœur
tu vois
c'est
je lui ouvre toute nue me souhaite la
bienvenue lui tout en baissant la tête
il me remet mes chaussettes il me
rajuste mes bottes
il remoulent sur mes seins mon
soutien-gorge en satin il rajuste le
tricot sur la blancheur de ma peau il
réglisse la ceinture dans les passants
de ma jupe puis sans me quitter des yeux
il rattache mes cheveux et devant moi
sans abris il a même refait le lit et
quand tout fut bien rangé bien propre
bien arrangé il a même comme il se doit
mes doigts
elle se redressa d'un bon avec un œil ou
furibond
le traita de Dieu c'est quoi tout en se
ruant sur moi et travaux de morts elle
me jette sur le lit et s'en veut quitter
des yeux elle a grippe mais je veux elle
arrache de mon trigo tout en portillon
ma peau elle enlève le ceinturon qui
connaît mon pantalon et elle se fera
elle se prend quand je apprends tout de
soutien-gorge puis elle enlève mes
bottes
et ma
toute
dans sa
et lorsque je fus tout nu
des beaux rêves tout cru
le premier poisson
qui se meurt dans un bocal d'eau
la bouche ouverte de ventre en l'air les
yeux comme des de l'automne je ne
suis pas le premier ballon
qui crève dans un ciel trouble
éclaté sous des coups des pingles d'un
petit garçon aux yeux creux tu n'es pas
le plus méchant noir
qui frissonnent devant ma porte et que
nous retrouvons matin
près des balles gros feuilles mortes tu
n'es pas la première qui t'a
accords de ce sont les
je ne suis pas le premier garçon
à qui tu disais terminé mais si ça peut
être
ça n'arrive pas seulement pas toi
ce que je viens de te chanter
d'autres moments des contrefoi
tu n'es pas le premier mouton
que les loups grillons dévorés
dans une forêt sans abri
par un hiver froid sans pitié
tu n'es pas le premier marin
in abandonné dans l'océan et dans les
apprenants secours sont années en départ
le front tu n'es pas le premier qui
miaule qui rate son évite de rideau
et que le crou espère Fouettard on voit
passer sur des livres et tout
tu n'es pas le premier
oiseau
qui s'est asphyxié dans sa classe
tu n'es pas le premier roman
dont je ne veux plus tourner les pages
si ça peut te consoler
ça n'arrive pas seulement à toi
ce que je viens de te chanter
d'autres me l'ont dit d'autres fois
tu n'es pas la première guitare
dont les corps de ce sont brisés
je suis pas le premier garçon
à qui tu dis c'est terminé
ne peut me consoler bon ça n'arrive pas
seulement rien qu'à moi
c'est que tu viens de me chanter
d'autres me l'ont dit autrefois
c'était pendant l'horreur d'une profonde
nuit je rentre et de câlins avec mes
musiciens quand tu es une grosse bête à
Paris sous la pluie faisant de l'eau de
stock comme un vulgaire humain je lui ai
dit monter il m'a répondu je suis le
loup-garou et toi dis donc tu
es chanteur comme
dans la musique
je chante pour les bambinos des petits
refrains rigolos mais le loup-garou m'a
dit italien
je vais vous jouer un truc sinon j'ai
plus qu'à tube c'est un animal les
oiseaux s'arrêtent d'assouiller
les ruisseaux s'arrêtent gargouiller
les martiens quittent se coupent et les
bébés mangent leurs soupe quand le
loup-garou joue le bouquet
et on lui une bête de scène alors je
l'ai pris en vedette américaine et je
lui présentais à luxe au Carpentier a
gagné la Drucker enfin au monde entier
bientôt ici raser ses petits camarades
encore un fou en haut des histoires
j'entends tous les soirs attendent à
présent dans le noir devant la télé le
loup-garou qui chante des contracté dans
le Languedoc à Tombouctou alors un homme
les gens se tapent que pour
le loup et restez jamais plaisir
les martiens quittent leur soucoupes et
les vrais mangeurs soupe quand le loup
garou joue le bouton
je suis là
que fais-tu
mon gars
il me rend fou ça me rend fou le bougalo
du loup-garou complètement fou
c'était un petit garçon très triste
pour nous seul avec son précepteur dans
une grande maison
il n'avait pas d'amis car il lui était
défendu de sortie
une petite fille soit le mur du parc et
alors
quand je serai le mur pour voir de
l'autre côté
j'ai cru que c'était comme dans un conte
de fées et moi tous mes jouets j'aurais
voulu les donner
qui a de l'autre côté
comment tu ne sais pas ce qu'il y a il y
a non je ne le sais pas dis-moi tout ce
qu'il y a toi
raconte-nous
dans la rue il y a des marelles dans la
rue il y a des cinémas dans la rue il y
a des manèges des motos comme ça et de
la
Barbapapa dans la rue à toute vitesse
dans la rue il y a des skateboard dans
la remette en mangeant des pop-corn
tout seul à émerveilleux dans notre
bandit il y a des filles et des garçons
je crois que si j'y vais je n'en
croirais pas mes yeux fais-moi voir qui
tu as bien retenu ta leçon rouge dans la
rue il y a des marées dans la rue il y a
des cinémas dans la rue il y a des
manèges
dans la rue à toute vitesse dans la rue
il y a des skateboard dans la rue il y a
le morchestre qui joue de la trompette
en mangeant des pommes
mon Dieu qu'est-ce que j'entends mais
vous parlez là quelqu'un
voilà Monsieur Bertrand est trop tard
pour se cacher
venez ici monsieur vous aide d'un
galopin quant à vous mademoiselle je
vous prie de retourner dans la rue là
est votre place dans la rue il y a des
cinémas dans la rue le péché menace des
motos comme ça et déjà barbares
dans
la rue il y a des skateboard dans la rue
il y a le orchestre qui joue de la
trompette en mangeant des
mais quelle heure est-il dans
il est peut-être temps de vous réveiller
même si c'est difficile à croire
vous êtes là et le jour et le
Quentin bonjour on peut vivre ses rêves
l'amour me pêche on est chacun
ressonnait dans ma maison il y a des
poètes dans ma maison il y a des
chansons
dans ma maison il y a des poètes dans ma
maison il y a des chansons
je faisais des rêves au fond de mes
rêves elle venait me retrouver
je faisais des songes profond de mes
anges on avait tant voyagé
mais elle m'a fait croire à la belle
histoire
compter elle m'a dit je t'aime moi j'ai
fait de même on ne va plus se quitter
dis donc Ding don't mais quelle heure
est-il dans l'amour me pêche chanter
tout à la journée ding dong dans la vie
est belle pendant mon jour en famille
dans mon mecsident l'amour me fait
chanter chacun la sonner dans la maison
il y a des poètes dans ma maison il y a
des chansons
dans ma maison il y a des toilettes dans
ma maison il y a des chansons
mais tant pis danser je me fais dans la
maison
il y a des chances
quand une fille une fille de Provence en
mariage vient de récemment toutes les
parents de la Provence s'en vont danser
jusqu'au petit matin quand une fille de
Provence en mariage bientôt les sabots
ce sont tous les films de la tendance
qui sont montés les amours il y a ton
père avec
l'ami dans ce comme une autre avatar il
y a ton grand-père et ma grand-mère qui
tout là-bas sont assis sur un banc il
est pas Nice l'attentalis le tester le
curé et moi je t'aime et moi je t'aime
autant que lorsqu'on était bien fait
quand une fille une fille de Provence en
maréchal je gagne les Samed toutes les
parents de la Provence s'envolant c'est
jusqu'au petit matin quand une fille ne
se dépendances en mariage viendrait sa
main ce sont tous les défauts de la
Provence qui sent mauvais
sous les tonnelles
dans l'équation on recherche un de
l'ombre les filles vont embrasser les
garçons les enfants sages et ne sont pas
sages mais aujourd'hui tout leur est
pardonné et moi je t'aime et moi je
t'aime autant que lorsqu'on était fiancé
toutes les parents donnent de la
Provence s'en vont danser jusqu'au petit
matin quand tu me fais une vie de
Provence en mariage bien connaît sa main
ce sont tous les livres de la Provence
qui s'en vont déposer les tambourins
ça prend mieux la rivière
et malheureux c'est celui qui va
ça c'est celui qui reste c'est moi
le plus malheureux les blancs c'est
celui qui reste
qui reste
c'est toi c'est pas sérieux d'être gay
comme ça dans une chanson
faut pas pleurer comme ça c'est bien ça
demain ou dans un mois tu n'y penseras
plus oh là là comme ça aujourd'hui c'est
pour toi que je suis venu gentil merci
pour toi ne dis rien si tu veux mais
sèche un peu tes yeux ne crois pas
surtout que nous autres s'en
tu sais ça tombe juste
celle que je veux me montrer mais bon il
cherchait à savoir d'où me vienne mes
joies je te connais et pourquoi ce
désespoir caché au fond de moi
qui est pas mal pas terrible on fait pas
ma mère moi partant je chante que de
bien la tendresse
c'est quelquefois le plus aimé mes êtres
heureux de se trouver
à nouveau de même les américains ils
font pas ça refaire pour quelques
instants je suis pas ma sœur
avec le cœur au bord des yeux j'ai des
paroles
la tendresse j'aime bien ce passage
parce que les paroles sont souvent la
tendresse
la tendresse c'est toi qui écris le
texte la tendresse bon je suis payé la
répétition
je peux te parler d'une histoire
ne pleure quand elle ne vient
pas il a la tête dont je lui dis je t'as
j'ai déjà goût
dans les coups de l'hôtel
de toi avec la voix
combien maintenant ça c'était la chasse
et qui ça c'était la chanson de la
petite fille de la maman et du papa
c'est celui qui a la tête dure qui a pas
de sans arrêt mais il n'arrive pas à
comprendre là je vais te montrer la
chanson du papa et
dans son vieux par-dessus frappé il s'en
allait lui vers l'été dans le petit
matin frileux mais fais pas froid en
Égypte mon vieux je pars de l'Égypte
par semaine le reste de la semaine on
bronze jours c'était la grève la graine
c'est le couscous
mais quand on agit seul
on a pas le cœur assez grand j'ai vu le
début
en pensant à tout ça je me dis des
exploits j'aimerais bien qu'il soit prêt
de voir
toute bien là
c'est quoi ce fait
je te l'offre
continue
le jardin extraordinaire tatouage
extraordinaire il y a des canards qui
parlent le temps
il remue leur derrière en me disant
aussi des statues qui se tiennent quand
tu veux du temps on dit ça mais moi je
sais que dès l'année venu s'en vont sur
le gazon
extraordinaire il y a des oiseaux
des petits morceaux de gruyère comme
clients ils ont et sous préfet
dans cette grande ville moussaille
touristes Samir pendant ce temps il
fallait bien trouver un lieu
par hasard tu parles par hasard dans ce
jardin et extraordinaire loin des lois
physiques des passages cloutés
pour saluer la lune dès que celle-ci
paru toute rose émotions
je crois ne va se brûler j'achète
jardin
la plus belle des filles elle va près de
moi après toi aussi et la vie sans
manière vous plaisez beaucoup j'aime les
hommes
et on change la feuille maintenant
fallait bien trouver dans cette grande
ville perverse une sortie amourette un
petit fleur de vingt ans
ce jardin
extraordinaire
du visage nous dit étendez-vous sur la
perte de bruyère je vous
joutais pendant que vous serez réunis
qui parle mais nous préférons que
François et moi
l'âme sœur une souchette secrète
je vais couvrir au fond du bois pour
ceux qui veulent savoir où se trouve il
est vous le voyez au cœur notre chanson
j'y veulent parfois mais pour la
couchette je crois que chagrin éprouve
il suffit pour ça d'un peu d'imagination
tu te rends compte un peu d'imagination
un jardin extraordinaire comme un monde
extraordinaire avec par exemple
pas du tout d'un Presario
pas du tout de métro boulot dodo avec ça
il suffit pour certains imagination
et voilà
les cerisiers sont blancs les oiseaux
sont contents revoilà le printemps et
oui
je dors mal dans mon lit ma cousine est
trop jolie à bientôt
c'est difficile
tourment fait rougir tout le temps
si je me marie est-ce que tu me
gonflerais moi alors vraiment
le petit pote est trop petit pour ça le
petit pas c'est encore un gamin et je
vis il court dans le jardin ne pense pas
aux filles mais moi les cerisiers sont
blancs et c'est très énervant décoller
d'un peu grand parcours
j'ai vu l'âge de jouer alors
qui vont
maman
les cerises semblables les oiseaux sont
en bas
quoi bonjour comme nature
j'aurais jamais cru ça elle savait jouer
dimanche soir
allez coucher
maman
les cerises et semblant et j'enlève son
compte
viens petit Cloclo dans mon comics
je dis streamer
que ça fait ça fait splash et ça fait ou
bien
parfois même
strip bien faire le début à faire
avec moi par-dessus les building ça fait
tant qu'on s'en veut les filles après
quoi je sais et ça fait bonus
vous prenez un risque tout le monde va
tourner son poste et bien on va essayer
de retenir les gens chez eux messieurs
le marteau 1 2 3 4
si j'avais un marteau je cognerai le
jour je conduirai la nuit allez-y
et le soir pour la soupe j'appellerai
mon père ma mère mes parents
merci
je vais vous dire deux trois titres
comme ça rapidement vous me direz si
vous en avez un plus qu'un autre j'y
pense et puis j'oublie ou pauvre petite
série
vous en souvenez non je m'en souviens
pas parce que mais j'aime bien c'est
très tendre très doux
3 4 toute seule
sur cette plage pauvre petite fille
riche
toute seule
si seul pour petite fille
tu pleures parce que tu n'as pas le
droit
d'épouser un pauvre garçon comme moi
pauvre petite fille riche
voilà
ce soir de novembre
c'est le soir des amis
qui a ma demande
ce sont tous réunis
et je me demande
s'il ne manquera rien
de toutes ces choses
qui font que l'on se sent bien entre
copains et je me demande
s'il n'en manquera pas
un seul de la bande pour chanter avec
moi
car la solitude
ce n'est pas toujours beau
être quelque chose
à me laisser par seul dans ma chambre
seule avec
du haut mais si tu chantes avec moi moi
je chante avec toi de chanter ensemble
c'est une drôle d'idée
pourtant il me semble
on fait bien d'essayer
car lorsque l'on chante comme ça en
famille
c'est tout autre chose
lorsqu'on est tout seul
entre temps
le chanteur très heureux quand il a un
micro le chanteur est très heureux quand
il chantant du haut la prochaine fois
comment sera tous
ensemble on
j'ai besoin qu'on m'aime mais personne
ne comprend ce que j'espère et que
j'attends qui pourrait me dire qui je
suis et j'ai bien peur toute ma vie
d'être incompris car aujourd'hui je me
sens mal t'aimer je suis le mal-aimé
mais j'en veux connaissent dès que je me
montrais mais ont-ils cherché à savoir
de me viennent mes joies et pourquoi ce
désespoir cacher au fond de moi
si les apparences sont quelquefois
contre moi je ne suis pas ce que l'on
croit
contre l'aventure de chaque jour je
changerai de main la joie d'un seul
amour mais je suis là dans
je suis le mal-aimé
j'en ai connaissent tel que je veux me
montrer mais ont-ils cherché à savoir
d'où me joie et pourquoi ce désespoir
caché au fond de moi
car je suis
mal aimé je suis mal aimé les gens me
connaissent tu me donnez pas que je veux
mais attention il cherchait
et pourquoi ce désespoir caché au fond
de moi oui car je suis
je suis le mal aimé
les gens me connaissent dès que je veux
me montrer monsieur Méon un coin
on a traque
les gens me connaissent tel que je veux
montrer mais on dit chercher à savoir
d'où me viennent mais joie et pourquoi
ce désespoir caché au fond de moi oui je
suis mal aimé je suis le mal-aimé
je suis le mal-aimé je suis
malade
mal aimé je suis le mal-aimé
les gens me connaissent telles que je
veux me montrer
ont-ils cherché à savoir d'où me vient
de mes joies et pourquoi se désespoir
caché au fond de moi
je suis mal aimé les gens me
connaissaient que je veux me montrer
ont-ils chercher à savoir d'où me vient
de mes choix et pourquoi ce espoir caché
au fond de moi
qu'elle m'avait une chanson du la
chanson en plus d'une façon absolument
on se trouve très naturel
parce que tu as une chemise et moi j'ai
l'impression d'être palette il faut se
mettre au diapason de ses invités
magnifique
il y avait la nuit quand on voulait se
voir un vieux vent souffle qui
a aujourd'hui je suis tout seul à le
revoir
tu es dans
le sens où mon cœur battant toi il me
reste
une chanson
sourire qui veut reviennent aujourd'hui
tous les
là
pour moi
et je suis prêt de pleurer
commence dans la prière est près de moi
je vais le vin
noir c'était un homme en déroute
il n'avait-il bien ni place
et sur les routes du lessive
sur les enquêtes sur la place
tous les gens
tous les mots
sont là
j'ai gagné
une sorte à nouveau pour moi pour toi
et je suis près de pleurer
comment ce temps-là hier est près de moi
à demain
hello
écoute maman est près de toi il faut lui
dire maman
c'est quelqu'un pour toi
bon je vais la chercher je crois qu'elle
est dans son bain et je suis pas
celle-là pouvoir venir
je t'en prie
l'important
mais il attend
papa ma maman elle ne fait toujours des
grands signes et elle me dit toujours
pas parce que je suis pas là
raconte moi comment est ta maison
apprends tu viens chaque soir
peut-être le son
oui mais quand même entre un c'est la
fête à l'école et à ce signature sur mon
car
net de leur papa pas moi
sinon depuis 6 ans
et si c'est ton âge mon enfant
ah non moi j'ai 5 ans mais si tu la
connaissais ma maman avant pour toi elle
m'a jamais parlé de toi tu restes là
me pleure quand elle vient
quand je lui crie
je t'aime et les fausses
meurent dans les fleurs il le téléphone
ne raccroche
je suis si près de toi
prochaine vacances à nouvel beau
rivages-tu la place
j'adore me baigner maintenant chez nager
mais disons comment tu connais l'hôtel
pour rivage
combien toutes les deux
moi je vous aime
je vous aime mais je t'ai jamais vu moi
c'est quoi ta joie mais tu pleures
pourquoi
ne pleure quand elle ne vient
quand je lui crie
je t'aime les mots sont morts dans les
couleurs et le téléphone
n'en aura
de toi avec la voix dit écoute-moi oui
lever les bras
Leclerc pour la dernière
car je serai
demain
au fond d'un
requins
elle est partie
si elle est partie alors
tant pis
Armstrong je ne suis pas noir
je suis plein de peau
quand on veut chanter l'espoir
duquel nous on te donne de beau oui je
vous vois le ciel
l'oiseau pour rien
combien de lui la rose les anges
je veux
noir et blanc
sont
ombres sont blancs
ce qu'il faut dire de fadaise
pouvoir enfin du fond de son lit
un soutien-gorge sur une chaise
une paire de bas sur un tapis
nous les coureurs d'un pays dont nous
les dents juste une ou les dons
mais chaque fois que l'on renifle
fraîche du jupon
pour un baiser pour une gifle
sans hésiter de nous repartons
la main fauteuse et l'œil nuisant nous
les dons du nous les
dons le seul problème qu'on se pose vous
c'est séparé en deux portions
55 kg de chair aux œufs de 50 g de nylon
c'est pas toujours un jeu d'enfant pour
le mannequin la main dure
l'hôtesse de l'air
le fruit soit mur ou qu'il soit vert
faut qu'on y avait le temps nous les
dons juju nous les dons
mais il arrive que le cœur s'accroche
aux épines d'une jolie femme
ou qu'elle nous mette dans sa proche
sous son mouchoir trempé de pleurs
c'est le temps j le plus fréquent pour
en don juju pour un Don Juan
nous les cocottes
tous les copains de souris
il faut alors livrer bataille
viens marcher vers la mairie
au bras d'une belle maman ouvre donc
les lumières
même quand la mort reviendra sonner
grand notre prière
sur un chapelet de grain de beauté
en attendant
jugement
nous l'aidons juju nous les dons
tous les accords diront
que tous les accords du
sol
ont eu des sanglot
quand vous redis est parti
il lame de fond
en balayer la ronde
de piste
où vole si il était bon
seule une fille aux cheveux roux comme
cloué sur une roue continue à tourner
avec ses bras de rien sans fous tourner
dans ce cheveu dans le soleil soudain de
plus court comme un soleil tout réunion
la nuit la fille tourne tout rayon celui
à
ne pas pour elle non tu pourrais non tu
n'es pas
monstre dit non non
tu descendre
j'en voudrais dire partir
si je lame de fond
à balayer la ronde de fils
c'est une fille aux cheveux roux comme
mon cloué sur une route continue à
tourner avec ses mains autour de son cou
tourner tourner dans ses cheveux roux
dans un désert qui fut
comme un soleil et tout réunion la nuit
et inspire tout en étant celui
qui vous les autres un mortel mais pas
pour elle non ça pourrait non tu n'es
pas mort on se redit non non
Freddy tu n'es pas mort tu es en chair
tu es en or tu es en os tu es en vie
continue à jouer vrai dire l'accordéon
c'est comme un coeur c'est comme une
bouche c'est comme une queue comme une
queue de pain qui fait la roue au fond
de mon ventre ça me fait trop rire
ça fait gonfler tout mes toiles toujours
de tous les attendus
d'une église
il disait je veux partir où le vent
manque des porteur
avec moi
à la Porte d'Italie nous commence le
voyage un camion une vie et tout son
rêve
d'où le soir
on s'engagera sur des bateaux on aura le
monde entier tu me laisses pas tomber
d'accord on ne sait rien faire
on peut tout faire on arrive juste à
voir pour leur donner un coup de main
mais parieurs au président ils sont
paumés les pauvres gens on aura le monde
entier tu te laisses pas tomber
merci d'être
notre père écoute-nous
nos supplions à genoux
à le monde nous avons tous Seigneur
nous avons
désobé
nous savons parfois
faire de l'amour qui fait des nouvelles
choses
qui fait la guerre
voici la guérison
de nos prisons déjà nous allons être
fort
tu vas nous éclairer
tu vas nous délivrer
nous serons sentir
et pour
nous faire un jardin préféré
du Sauveur qui parle
espagnol
qui partage nos malheurs
par l'amour
qui
nous conduit
par sa beauté infinie
pitié pour nous
je ne sais rien et voilà qu'aujourd'hui
je suis le gardien du sommeil de se nuit
je l'aime à mourir
pour vous détruire tout ce qui vous
plaira à couvrir l'espace de ses bras
pour tout reconstruire pour tout
reconstruire je l'aime à mourir
elle a dû faire tout les guerres pour
être si forte aujourd'hui elle a dû
faire toutes les guerres de la vie
et l'amour aussi ainsi
j'imagine le feu sous la cendre du feu
dans mes veines un soleil de nuit
ton plaisir
et toujours le matin très est
j'imagine ces gestes citant qui font de
l'amour
et que l'amour
et j'attends chaque instance que joue et
j'attends chaque nuit t'aurait tout
quand tu n'es plus la
je te cherche
encore
quand tu
mets
la plus peuple
et debout devant moi
il dit
que pour toi cette moto j'aime beaucoup
dans lequel
rouge
je sais l'amour fait l'amour des cours
je te ferai tout oublier
en utilisant le bras du flic coquin
de la reine
si je mange mon mail dans un billet de
choix qu'importe ma tenue de SNL
sont pas
de même le monde
dans l'hôpital
parce que là
j'ai oublié de l'oublier
elle qui était mon passé
cet amour
hon
j'ai oublié de l'oublier
car ce rêve in achevée
était
beau et pétard le rêve
que je sache rester encore amour
me rendrait si malheureux de plus rêver
ne plus penser
à tous les deux
j'ai oublié de l'oublier moi qui ne
voulait plus l'aimer
c'est à vous que l'orgueil
j'ai oublié de l'oublier
mais je voulais me prouver
qu'il me tait possible
soit à sa place
il ne faut pas que je sache rester
encore amoureux
me rendrait si malheureuse le plus rêver
de plus penser
à tous les deux
j'ai demain et 10 doigts qui fatigue et
de plus Le Portel sur moi
je ne sais faire que l'amour dans ses
bois
je ne connais qu'une chose je ne sais à
faire autre je ne sais pas claire
godet
une place à la Faculté c'est pourquoi je
viens tout t'expliquer
je ne sais pas que l'amour
et ben voilà
en histoire commence lorsque je te fais
jeune lorsque j'allais à l'école
les filles étaient jolies jamais vos
couleurs amis
quelqu'un possédait mon cœur
ah je me l'avoue oui j'étais fou de la
maîtresse aux yeux doux
elle ressemble est un ange sans regarder
moi petit garçon
je me disais comme de ses étranges
ah je peux oui j'en suis fou de la
maîtresse aux yeux si tu veux
moi je me présente
aucune vous êtes toute ma vie monnaie
un passionné le bruit
plus les
mecs toujours la même je suis les forger
ignores tu m'as dit faire tu savais
briller
je vais apprendre à ne plus parler
découvrir
lui-même
quoi
du coup de coudre
je le voudrais que toi
le coup du coup de poudre
retournera sur moi
on ne peut pas vivre seul comme tu le
fais
le bonheur n'est jamais seul où ça se
saurait
que je suis sur terre
je vais apprendre à ne plus parler
découvrir l'humilité
oublier mes
tu fais ça je te voudrais
je ne voudrais que toi
sur moi
tu devras ah oui mon cœur
retournera sur moi
quand on aura chez moi
je te voudrais te voir
je voudrais
je voudrais que toi
regarde la ma ville s'appelle
vivre là-dedans ce que ton les vieux qui
ont la peau douce la bande pour manger
dans les chambres d'herbe pousse pour y
dormir faut se pousser les gosser jour
mais le ballon c'est une boîte de
sardines
moi
aussi
on peut se
parler bientôt bien
au château attends je t'attends camarade
bientôt bientôt je t'attends je
t'attends camarade
mon amour
pour ton mariage
avant de tourner la page et de quitter
ta famille soit fidèle à ton amour
tu sais que je t'aime alors n'est pas
trop de peine je suis ta petite fille
pour toujours
que la vie passe bien vite ne pleure pas
je te revois petite mais avec toi que
j'ai ouvert mon cœur à tous les secrets
du bonheur
quand on partait tous les deux mains
dans la main prends mon était heureuse
sur ce chemin pour les enfants
s'envolent un beau matin
mon enfant mon
âme te voilà
presque une femme et comme ta maman si
belle sois fidèle à ton amour
mes fans qui tue mes grands pas la
solitude je viendrai comme d'habitude
chaque jour
que de bonheur partagé toute une vie qui
semble s'éloigner mais aujourd'hui c'est
un grand jour
je dois te le donner dis-moi pourquoi
c'est la lumière du ciel qui nous suivra
pour vous avez je pensais tous les deux
chansons mais pendant ce long voyage
soit fidèle la ton amour
quel que soit
la paix aujourd'hui sans aucun doute
c'est nos cœurs que l'on partage pour
toujours
j'ai pas besoin de voir celle que j'aime
sur les couverts des journaux
j'aime mieux être avec elle sans
problème
avoir un couteau
c'est pas une star qui me faut
j'ai rêvé d'une fille toute simple qui
me parle d'amour
sans faire semblant
j'ai rêvé d'une vie toute simple qui me
parle d'amour
simplement
est-ce que par hasard moi et je vous
aime de cinéma
ne font rien je n'y crois pas
peu à scénario fait pour moi
et toi vrai
c'est pas vous qui me faut
je rêve d'un garçon tout simple qui me
pardonne
sans faire semblant
je rêve d'un garçon tout simple qui m'en
parle d'amour
simplement
est-ce que par hasard j'ai pas besoin de
voir celle que j'aime
soir à la télévision
plutôt que l'entendre sur les antennes
j'aime mieux la voir la maison
c'est pas une star qui me faut
j'ai rêvé d'une fille toute seule qui me
parle d'amour
ton frère semblant
j'ai rêvé du titre toute seule qui me
parle d'amour
simplement
est-ce que par hasard j'ai pas besoin
d'un cameraman
c'est mes psychographes
j'ai pas besoin d'un metteur en scène
je sais bien ce qu'il me faut
j'arrête au cœur de ça qui me parle
comme
semblant
je rêverais un garçon tout simple qui me
parle d'amour
simplement
est-ce que par
de quelqu'un de simple qui me parle
d'amour
sans faire semblant
je rêve quelqu'un de simple qui me parle
d'amour
simplement
elle se bataille
bonjour c'est vous qui venez pour la
chanson
j'ai oublié les mots de ma chanson et
Makita à la maison
le sang c'est moi en moi le premier
couplet et je vous dirai tout ça me
plaît
je vous aime
c'est pour comme je vous aime c'est
idiot mais vrai quand même
je ne me souviens de rien de plus mais
je vous aime
vous avez dit je vous aime
c'est très joli je vous salue et on a
jamais fait avant
je vous écris des chansons d'amour
j'y mettrai tout mon cœur
oh je vous attendais depuis si longtemps
je
peux maintenant
je vous aime
vous avez dit je m'en souviens plus je
vous aime
c'est très joli je vous aime et puis je
ne me souviens plus
je vous aime
c'est tout comme tu rêves
c'est très joli je vous aime
on ne me l'a jamais dit avant je vous
aime
comme je vous aime
ses rêves solide avant
comme je vous aime bien
c'est le moment des gars déjà de on
varier un peu
veuillez nous chanter la ballade la
ballade des gens heureux tu n'es pas
très bien éveiller le chantait la balade
mais si la balade des gens sur
improviser la mélodie était très jolie
tu peux chanter ce qui me vient comme ça
oui
voici le moment des grillades nous
allons boire un verre ou de et alors
nous allons chanter la balade la balade
des gens
nous allons chanter la balade le cheval
numéro 3 numéro 4
numéro 1 numéro 2 pourquoi pas je vais
vous chanter la balade
des gens heureux
tenter la balade la balade des gens
marcher vous donne la colade
Giscard vous parle au coin du feu à
demi-centre la patate la balade des gens
se veut
à la saison départ
de pour mieux protéger la balade la
balade les gens heureux pour mieux
protéger la balade la balade des gens se
veut
et comme ça les pauvres diable n'ont pas
besoin de voir les cieux ils n'ont qu'à
chanter la balle la balade des gens
heureux
ux ils l'ont à chanter la balade
les gens heureux
venez si je reste en rade car ce soir je
suis malheureux même en vous chantant la
balade la balade les gens heureux même
en nous chantant la balade la ballade
les gens heureux
l'amour ce fruit défendu vous est donc
inconnu à cela ce petit joli petit
bourgeon d'avril non je ne l'ai jamais
vu jamais vu ni connu
ce temps perdues
à ton cœur me semble encore hésité cher
13 ans mais je veux tout oser pour un
petit tout petit baiser un vertigeonner
Bluewin
ce n'est pas dans mes frères car je suis
pas mignon
roi mon corps au fond des bois
aussi
je comprends bien tu me demandes
tu viens
je te veux sous les pages je te veux
sous les palettes et mon ne sont pas les
promotionnels
si je comprends bien tu m'as demandé
vos mes amis
mes souvenirs
si vous la voyez revenir
dites-lui que mon coeur lassé
vient de rompre avec le passé
je tire ma révérence
et mauvais au hasard
par les routes de France
et de la balle mais dites-lui quand même
simplement
je l'aime
dites-lui voulez-vous
bonjour pour moi et voilà tout
j'avais son espérance j'étais en sale
bordel
hélas les apparences
et le sort sans trompeur
un autre a pris ma place tout passe tout
casse tout la seule de grands mots
pourquoi non
bonjour pour moi
et le croit que j'ai beaucoup de chagrin
aujourd'hui non mais peut-être demain
je n'ai plus d'espérance
je remporte mon cœur
par les routes de France
ou bien d'ailleurs
mais dites-lui quand même simplement
je l'aime
celui voulez-vous bonjour pour moi
bonjour pour nous
et voilà
c'est gentil de m'avoir accompagné
jusqu'à la gare
et tous ces bonbons
savez-vous que c'est la première fois
que nous nous quittons depuis que c'est
arrivé remarquez ça va faire que 15
jours
vous avez déjà pensé à ce que ça faisait
peur à 15 jours
mais moi je pensais puisque vous partez
en voyage
ce que nous nous quittons ce soir
mon cœur fait son apprentissage
voyez j'ai posé vos bagages
marche avant côté du couloir
et pour les grands signaux d'usage
j'ai préparé mon grand mouchoir
dans un instant le train des morts vous
resterez seul sur le quai
et je vous verrai de la gare
me dire adieu là-bas avec votre bouquet
promettez-moi d'être bien sage
de penser à moi
et revenez dans notre cage
votre retour
je trouvais une place dans un
compartiment où il y a juste une grosse
dame et dans un coin et un curé avec une
grande barbe blanche
et l'autre c'est la
limitation de la bienheureuse Ernestine
ça vous plaît
puisque vous partez en voyage
vous m'avez promis ma chérie
de m'écrire 14 pages
tous les matins où t'avance
pour que je vois votre visage
et c'est la vitre je vous prie
c'est affreux je perds tout courage
et moi je déteste Paris
le contrôleur crie en voiture
le cochon il fait pourtant bien
que je dois rester mais je jure
que s'il crie encore une fois moi je
viens
j'ai mon amour pour ce bagage
et tout le reste
je m'en fous
puisque vous partez en voyage
mon
chéri je pars avec vous
ne fut qu'un petit bal de rien
à balle en plein
quel beau jour pour moi
une extra des deux musiciens
ne joint pas souvent
vous étiez très près de moi
ce ne fut qu'à voyage en train
retour en métro oui mais
quel beau jour pour moi
un couloir où nous étions bien
quinze ou 23
oui mais vous étiez près de moi
bravo
chérie
lorsque nous
nous sommes la seule
quand sur vos lèvres
j'ai pris
ce baiser après avoir dansé
cela fut un mariage d'amour
un douce histoire de mal ouais
quel beau jour pour moi
ce sera le bonheur toujours
on ne sait jamais
si vous m'aimez autant
que moi
ce sera le bonheur toujours
si jamais
et vous m'aimez autant
que moi
si mes autres
en passant
comme un dent apprendre quelques mots
d'anglais avec vous c'est ça qui serait
sous et je vous dis à do you do que même
répondez vous et mon ange n'est pas le
temps et je ne dis pas I Love You car je
ne dis pas tout plus tard on verra mais
pour l'instant
quel est le signe attendez et nous
allons faire la mairie j'ai une chanson
dans la tête ce n'est pas au courant de
peut-être le ciel est bleu sur
l'Atlantique les amoureux c'est
magnifique sans renseigner vers de
nouveaux pays qui venaient dans mon lit
comment peut-on parler anglais sans
accent comment
mais mon enfant vous voyez que pour
l'instant je n'ai pas le temps pour être
pour se voir à New York
s dans New York
de Broadway
le ciel est bleu sur la cantine et nous
allons faire la mairie j'ai une chanson
dans la tête ce n'est pas encore l'amour
est peut-être le ciel est bleu sur la
sortie les amours c'est magnifique sans
bons et des verbes d'aujourd'hui
chanson dans la tête